what's up it's your boy vic check me out
in the bootleg calf podcast
yo blue lighthead podcast man special
guest in here my guy victor burnett yes
sir okay victor ruler is here man what's
good bro welcome appreciate you having
me for people who don't know um you are
you manage blast
you're are you like the ceo of eagle i'm
the president the president of eagle
business partners we own eagle together
yeah so first of all congrats on like an
amazing last year and a half or so like
i feel like
you know blast went from being like la's
best kept secret
um to being the i mean
one of the biggest artists in the
country yeah um you guys just hit number
one on two formats at radio like right
um
kind of take me back to the beginning
though how did you get involved with
blast because like i said he's been
around for like people act like he's
like a new artist but he's really not
yeah he's been around for a minute i
mean me honestly i didn't know blasphemy
like until like 2017 because i was in
college so i went to university of
washington so i moved to seattle and i'm
going to grasp that the huskies yeah and
then i played football there and then i
ended up going to grad school at
southern illinois so i went to illinois
after that i was gone for like six years
a lot of school what were you going to
school for so i got a bachelor's in
journalism advertising and i got a
bachelor's of psychology and then i went
to grad school for pr media development
so
yeah culmination all that and you're
just a one-stop shop if i need a shrink
and a pr guy exactly exactly exactly yes
i mean
um when i moved back home from college i
started working for benny boom and then
so i was working at their production
studio on college
video director
so i really started working like on the
post production part of the tupac movie
so i was doing a lot of like merchandise
design product development for them
right i was like that's what i was like
doing internships for in college
um and they really just kind of like
transitioned into doing a bunch of stuff
in the company and they ended up letting
me after i worked with uh i did some
stuff for dame dash too like damn dash
studios because we're doing like the
back end all the internet digital
distribution so doing merchandise
production with him too with like the
ceo brand the wine and the whiskey we
were just over there a couple weeks ago
yeah
yeah he was uh he was jamming out and we
were on shrooms and okay that's crazy it
was a i mean it was oh you took shoes
with damn dash yes
that's wow it was he was like i was like
of course let's go yeah and and that's
you get the podcast on insurance yes 100
a thousand percent well i gotta go back
and watch that again because i'm like
that's different one million percent at
the end i kind of alluded to it and he
was like yeah i don't say it you know
because this is technically illegal i
was like well look i took shrooms i
don't know what he did
yes i mean so with the with after the
damn dash situation i pretty much took
over the product merchandising
department at their production company
all right dames
yep and so um i convinced him to let me
like
take over the studio and like manage a
studio on a facility it was already like
a podcast room
but me and my boy was already interning
there so i'm like let's just have them
build the studio and put the actual
equipment in here for us to like run it
up right so they said they shot us the
live and let us do that and then pretty
much i was doing
like consultations with with independent
artists on teaching them how to monetize
content and teaching them like digital
distribution platforms and how to do it
at what time to do it how to like pretty
much beat the algorithm as an
independent artist so i was charging for
that then i added on the studio services
to that and so um eventually
i met blast and jason cash on the same
day actually shout out to both of them
yeah shout out to both of them so they
both pulled up to the studio with the
actor that played tupac demetrious [ __ ]
yep
yep so [ __ ] he plays the piano as well
so that was pretty much all just coming
up to use the studio to start making
music so i got introduced to all with
both of those two at the same time and
then really i'll take a liking to
birthday music to be honest with you um
but blast was the one actually
consistently rendering the studio off
for me
and so like you know blast is pretty
much like a man of little words so one
day i just knocked on the door it was
like bro he ran the studio from me like
five times and they said [ __ ] like what
are you doing here right right so he
playing me music
he played me savage first and i was like
without be noticed before he even knew
beno so played me that played me a
couple other songs played me some videos
so i started asking questions like who
produced it he's like me
every answer was me every answer is me
from production graphic design post
production on the video merchandise
whole vision i'm like [ __ ] i'm like but
why are you in the why are you in this
great space like what what is it that
you actually missing and so we just
started having a conversation and i was
like well this is what i do that's what
i went to school for i'll do it for free
for you just to see if you like what it
is that i'm actually trying to teach and
then if it worked let's just keep
applying it so i just started off doing
like marketing marketing campaigns
rollouts like hand-to-hand stuff for
consumers
um ended up taking over the merchandise
and then we just kept working helping on
videos helping doing creative and then
one day we went to the studio he just
like used to be my manager
like just randomly uh in there was this
prior to the first six tape yeah
yeah so that's all prior to the first
six tape um this is probably like
six months before that
so yeah so i was working with him for a
whole year and some change before i even
became his manager
um so yeah you know just like the
dedication in a day-to-day grind we was
together every day we were starting to
be together every day and it wasn't a
lot of like having a lot of business
conversations um
and it is you know his musical talent
just and then added with our natural
business acumen and like the [ __ ] i went
to school for and studying all that type
of stuff
came together and it was like baking
soda and vinegar yo it's crazy because
like
you went to school for all of
so much different things yeah i'm sure a
lot of that you ended up applying to
what you're doing now for sure because a
lot of people are like well you know if
you want to be in the music industry you
really don't got to go to school but
like i feel like a lot of people who do
go to school it ends up helping them out
yeah because there's so much you can
apply to
any sort of situation i'm sure 100
percent um the psychology part first is
just like
just understanding people and
understanding how to move in different
rooms and just understanding how to
switch faces being in different places
whether it's in the streets whether it's
in a boardroom whether it's in the
classroom
so that that really helped me out a lot
just being able to speak the language of
a lot of different people um
journalism perspective like just getting
like write-ups and [ __ ] done right on
one sheet and understanding how to put
that in format
and then [ __ ] the pr part it just speaks
of course of course i just understood
that
marketing so and i was around the time
where
instagram started to actually develop an
algorithm when i was in college so it
wasn't really a algorithm yet but that
was what they were teaching us in class
so it was like i was just learning it so
fast early on not knowing that the music
[ __ ] was gonna be able to be applied to
it you mentioned blast being in like
kind of a gray space
prior which i feel like a lot of artists
that we we both might know or there's a
lot of artists out there that are really
talented that
might be kind of wrapped up in that grey
space
what is like advice you would give to
somebody who has all of the tools
necessary to make this [ __ ] work but
just really can't get over the hump
maybe
[ __ ] build a great team
because i mean it's not it's not just me
and blast like of course crazy just had
just me and blast like we still got
four
employees on full payroll well early on
it was just youtube though well early on
it was just us two i mean we had a
videographer you know what i'm saying so
he was trailing us and taking all the
pictures and all the bts right um but i
think
right after
probably like a little bit after that
first six tape that's when we actually
nah actually during the first six tape
that's when we started hiring people so
we made like our first hire her name is
allison so she's our general manager and
she's our she's a blast tour manager too
so but
same time everybody is like super
qualified like alison went to school and
got a degree in music business and audio
engineering wow so she qualified to have
these audio conversations on stage as a
tour manager and then she's also
qualified to you know have those first
conversations run the email right be the
first responder when it's talking about
actual business logistics so you know
that's and that's really like a constant
theme throughout the whole company like
everybody is highly qualified for the
job they do but i would say the same
thing for artists that's in that
position like
i mean obviously i don't i'm really a
proponent of like you know reading the
manager to you got some [ __ ] to manage
you know what i'm saying like if you're
not overwhelmed with [ __ ]
you really don't need a manager at that
point you know what i mean you just
really need somebody to actually help
you probably funnel your ideas and
actually like get to the point because
you can only be one place at one time so
if you want to be in the studio you may
need somebody to help you make the merch
a little creative on that
because blast is really an anomaly when
it comes to doing all that [ __ ] i really
just like yeah it's really just him and
like i mean russ i guess was similar but
i mean i don't think russell's a creator
tyler
but yeah i mean just like in terms of
like engineering yourself
yeah but i don't even think they do
graphic stuff i was gonna say the one
thing i'm not sure russ is making his
own i don't think he's photoshopping bro
we went on tour for this uh this tour in
september
first city was seattle so you know they
got cell graphics and [ __ ] on yeah yeah
so blast was like i'm not happy with the
graphic that like the graphic designer
delivered me so i'm just about to chill
today literally spent 14 hours in the
hotel making his whole show graphic for
the concert wow so it was like an hour
and a half reel of a whole bunch of [ __ ]
going but he created that himself what's
going on behind him while he's
performing he made that himself made all
that [ __ ] so it's just like for me you
know it's like a cheat code at the end
of the day it's like you don't really
got to outsource that much
can you save money facts is the
definition of vertical integration like
all money in for sure you really don't
got to spend i mean our marketing
budgets be so low just because we don't
got to outsource for engineers we don't
got to outsource for graphic artists
motion graphic artists so it just gives
us a lot of time to work with capital
and actually distribute it how we want
to oppose to being like we being spread
then because we got to pay all these
people to do a job
yeah i think it's i mean it's a it's a
nice convenient thing to have in your
pocket because most artists everything
has a bill uh
a recuperable bill yeah
so that thing going on behind blast head
you know mozart is probably face up with
fifteen hundred dollars for some [ __ ]
like that's like fifteen thousand that's
[ __ ] crazy it's crazy people are
getting over on [ __ ] out here
definitely that's a lot of money but
[ __ ] that tedious work people don't want
to do so they'd be like i'm about to
whip you over the head for it yo that's
crazy and so when you guys uh obviously
you know i feel like there was like a a
real
real organic buzz about blast like i had
heard about blast
before six tape because you know
obviously i did the show ahead and
head's been a huge proponent of blast
since forever him and salas um and uh so
i was kind of already hip to like
you know his talents and you know head
was like you don't like this dude does
it all like makes the beat records
himself and yeah
and um
so well i remember when six tape first
came out
talking to my guy byes who was working
beno over at dev jam
and like everyone was like yo but you
know i mean obviously i love being
but everyone was like yo but the blast
guy is also like that guy too like you
know what i'm saying and i think that um
that was kind of the beginning i feel
like where like a lot of discussions are
being had but like what what i feel like
you guys probably i'd actually kind of
know inside information that you guys
had a lot of situations on the table
what was it about red bull music
because that caught a lot of people off
guard yeah what was it about the rebel
situation that you guys were like
this fits because it obviously worked it
was the first time you guys are the
first people to make that work yeah in
the hip-hop space for sure for sure um
it was a culmination of a couple things
right like we understood what we wanted
from a business aspect
like if you look at eagle you could take
like
all money in opm
uh a tde
and
somebody's formula like a e40
and just combine all those together and
we just understood like one ownership
because blast was a producer as well so
we were already doing so much money in
merch and he was already doing enough
money on distrokid from his production
catalog and his artist catalog that it
was like
we ain't got to take 20 000 right now
because the [ __ ] can make twenty
thousand dollars in a month just off his
natural services that he does as a
creator so that was how we first stepped
in the room two like i said like most
people don't expect somebody to come in
and have an educational conversation
like especially like a young black dude
that's under 30 and has never worked in
music before because i never worked in
music before blast so me having these
conversations were like super raw anyway
but shout out to our lawyer our lawyer
is 29 too
and so
professor at drexel university got a
sports firm got his own lawsuit
all that [ __ ] can we get can we get the
lawyers can we get a name drop on the
lawyer carl folks for shout out to your
local folks shout out to the lawyer so
i mean just with us three walking in the
building together
it's kind of like you really crossed all
the t's and dot all the eyes with that
because it's like you got your legal
assistance right there then you got me
who actually understands like business
structure business development and then
we came with an actual staff with actual
vision with a brand with color schemes
or already visuals put out so i already
know when you come to the table with
that much
there's really not much you can really
give us in that space it's more so just
like what you can throw what gas you
could throw on the flame that's already
kind of like heating up but overall i
just understood red bull is a privately
owned company so they're like they're
not on the stock market which means that
if they gross in 4 billion a year that
means they're doing something
right but lastly i did my my senior
dissertation on red bull because i wrote
my paper on vertical integration and red
bull is a marketing company
to start off it wasn't an energy drink
so that's where you see all these
advertisements all these events and all
that type of stuff just sources from
them being a marketing company so me
writing that paper i already understood
too like
we can make so much money that's
non-recupable
that is like we'll make more money in
our recruitable funds than advances just
because red bull got so much stuff i.e
the f1s um the events the extreme sports
games the skydiving all right
they're the airplane [ __ ] they got all
kinds of things
we get so much money off of
sync plays from internal red bull
sources that it's like we can make so
much money and just keep recouping every
advance by just deferring that of the
appearance fees we're getting so
the way that we can cr like cross
collateralizing most of the time is like
negative because it's like most people
going a whole from cross-collateralizing
whether it be like a producer
cross-collateralized with an artist or
however it goes
but in this sense
we crossing over between red bull music
rare bull culture team red bull extreme
sports and we're going through all these
different facets of red bull and we get
money with these different divisions but
all these different places got their own
ceos you know what i'm saying they all
their own different branches of red bull
all this [ __ ] is not under one mm-hmm so
you know just with breaking the artist
and understanding creativity and
understanding that blast was like a
super creative artist on top of
everything i was just like bro you
really need to go somewhere where
somebody can like tap into your talents
and actually bring your talents out like
have you designed some [ __ ] for the f1
speedway to where that [ __ ] gets
featured and then you get a royalty off
all this merch that's sold worldwide wow
so
just that type of thingy so
because when we think of like the
traditional record deal right like
most artists would come off the street
take a cute as big of an advance as they
can get right but then
you know two years later they complain
they've never seen a check off of music
well it's because you've never recouped
right so when you guys went to red bull
you figured out kind of a life hack if
we go to red bull we can get so much
money within red bull that we don't have
to really ever worry about yeah and you
know i take a crazy advance up front
because you know like like you said you
were in a position where he was making
so much money off distro kid and
you know a lot of people go for that
first they want the bigger advance but
it's like if you don't need the advance
why do you take it it's a shitty loan
right honestly brothers like it's a
precedent we ought to say for real for
real because i mean it's
saying it's deeper than rap is kind of
cliche but it's really deeper than rap
though you know because we already just
seen the people go
be superstars but didn't have nothing at
the end
i mean meek mill just complained about
this i mean a lot of people who we look
are like not 100 percent a lot of our
favorite people are like aren't seeing
money off their
they exactly they got to stretch that
check but which is why they didn't
really be killing themselves over doing
so many shows and being on the road so
much to see that upfront ticket sale you
know what i mean so just like i already
knew
you don't want to stretch yourself out
with anything you do so however you can
create fillers in between the time that
you want to take breaks throughout
creativity okay what is the best avenue
to be able to do that so
not having to take a crazy advance but
still being able to make six figures
plus just on outside entities within the
company is like oh that's guaranteed
checks i'm gonna get just because i'm
doing business with the companies and
they best favor to make me happy and
vice versa so you know it's just i think
that uh i told the people at red bull
when we signed i was like really pretty
much this is us being the cool kids
coming to sit with the nerds and making
the nerves popular
and i'm like but it's mutually
beneficial because the nerves you got
the answers to all the tests so i'm like
i'm not tripping off kicking in with the
nerves because i see the mutual
beneficiary part of the whole thing
also too i think you guys are in a great
position too where it's like red bull is
i'm sure their music division doesn't
have to make money
because they have so much other [ __ ]
going on yeah i mean it's damn they're
like a guinea pig
i'm saying it's like i guess they
started this you know what i mean like
it's like it's like when we think of red
bull like the 11th thing we probably
think about is the fact oh they put
music out too yeah but i mean just a
note they got rock bands going platinum
i didn't know that i didn't know that so
yeah yeah it's like they got a band
called bear tooth and they got these
girls called the aces like they both go
crazy um they sell out crazy product
crazy merchandising like them type of
deals
is like really what like entices me
because i already know but you don't
really you make pennies on a dollar on
music you feel me even if you got a very
favorable deal it's just like streams
just don't pay you that much for you to
sit there and be like i can make all my
money off that so it's like i believe in
physical product and actually you know
branching out and investing is actual
money we got going on and different [ __ ]
that's gonna make us way more money so
grand scheme of things just like yeah we
just decided to take the steps over the
elevator for real for
because we could have jumped it so many
times we had crazy outlandish offers on
the table you know i heard but
it's just like [ __ ] you know we know we
want and we know how we want to move and
we understand it's like okay
the same amount of money if we get this
lump sum
we understand music math and i think
that's a big problem like a lot of
people don't understand music math and
how that actually works because it's
like even if you got a 50 50 deal you
got to make double what you what you uh
got given to even make your recruitment
back so it's like and that's a 50 50 so
i think if you got less than 50 you're
[ __ ] you're [ __ ] yeah you feel me so
but
having those small nuances and having
that intelligence behind that part i
think that helped us navigate a lot just
through this house talk about music math
because i i tr we talk about it a lot on
the podcast where i try to tell people
like hey look if you take a let's say a
hundred thousand dollars
and you have a
50 50 is an easy number for you to
understand yeah right
when your money comes in for your music
the money the balance that you owe only
they're advancing you money on your half
of them of the bread right exactly so
like you said you have to make
two hundred thousand dollars
to be
tested
right to get back even but the [ __ ] that
part is like
even though you didn't made your two
hundred thousand back you didn't already
made them two hundred thousand two yeah
they're making it really made a half a
million before you even
anything so this is like understand and
then you think about taxes
taxes i mean think about most deals
yeah a favorable deal would be like
getting 13 or 15 points off your music
if you're in a major situation so then
then let your mind wrap around how much
of a [ __ ] shitty situation that is
it's ridiculous it's ridiculous but
you know it's
some people just don't give a [ __ ] yeah
like you know me and headed during the
pandemic we we had yg on and he said he
had never seen a deaf damn deaf jam
check like off of his music like he said
this during an interview yeah i remember
this i'm not speaking on anything that
he i've seen it i've seen it for sure
and uh it's like yeah well you know
at the end of the day like you take that
that that every time you drop an album
if it's a check associated with that
like
you know that's the money you take in
the front i mean i had an artist ask me
yesterday like
how do i not be bitter about this stuff
and i was honestly just like you just
got to take ownership of where you at
with it and where you signed your name
on the dotted line because it's like you
can you sign the deal right like you can
kick and fight all you want to but you
had ample chance to like review this
take it to whoever else you wanted to
review it and then you made your
decision it's not people don't want the
slow steady check
they want that upfront nut yeah because
they want to get they want to be a part
of like the smoking mirror [ __ ] yeah and
it's like wouldn't you rather have like
15 grand a month bro but when i figure i
figured out like
all this [ __ ] is smoking mirrors at the
end of the day because me i also used to
design all the clothes for like all the
v live strip clubs and [ __ ] because that
was like a contract they had to benny
boom like really they was getting all
the merchandise there was a v live in
phoenix yup vlogging phoenix going out
here i should make all the shirts
hoodies like all the [ __ ] for themselves
place was a death trap by the way
so even going to be live right i'm
noticing like i'm seeing the artists do
walk throughs and i'm seeing the manager
come collect the back end and they also
getting
five seven thousand of ones though just
complimentary ones that throw back to
the house so it's like in yo mind you
like okay you trying to compete like
they got the street dudes competing with
the rappers trying to see who can buy
more bottles who could throw more money
so you're saying the back end would
include your actual back end and then
the club would be like
here's some money as well to throw
exactly it's just because it's gonna
come they just say you gotta throw it
all though yeah so it's gonna come right
back to the house it's just gonna entice
everybody else to feel like oh
such-and-such is in here blowing the
bags now the dope dealers the dog
y'all gonna buy the bottles right so on
one side it's comped on the other side
it's like you spending your money
so
when it comes down to that and
understanding like tax write-offs all
that type of [ __ ] like how to write off
jewelry it become a whole different ball
game when you understand that rather
than you just being like i just want to
spend my cash right now for it
yeah i think uh the tax write-off thing
is how how do you write off jewelry give
us
help us understand that because yeah so
like this right here like well one gold
is an investment it's a mineral true so
it can go up in value and it has
universal trade value true so
in the simplest term
it's like the the government is like if
you're going to invest in an asset
whether it's property or the jury then
you can write that off because you're
basically saying this is a future
investment for me to be able to do
something with it um and as far as
dependent it has my
my actual brand on there i'm owner of
the company i'm on the paperwork so i'm
able to say this is a costume fee or
promotional fee for my company and just
be able to write it off at the end of
the year rather than me spending upfront
cash so
let's say technically my my tax bill at
the end of the year was 30 000. if i
spend fifteen thousand on this chain i
only gotta spend i only gotta pay
fifteen thousand of that back to the
government and the other fifteen
thousand goes down there's a write-off
through jewelry costume expense all that
so it's like the simplest way i guess
you could say it
and most people who are buying jewelry
don't do don't write their [ __ ] no they
don't
know
they don't appraise it they don't do
nothing you feel me oh that [ __ ] is tax
deferrable so just really understanding
how to like move around that type of
spectrum rather than just what are some
other things like you like like
obviously you know for people who don't
know like obviously you know if you if
you own your own llc or or your
you can write off certain meals you can
write out certain things but what are
meals i think i think the biggest thing
for like entrepreneurs and business
people you can give students college
credit
like we've had like two interns that
we've given three to five college
credits based off of a simple curriculum
we built submitted it did you have to
pay them no
i didn't know that because i know at
iheart they had like banned interns for
a while because there was some lawsuit
yeah so i mean radio but see you know
credits cost money in college though so
if you're giving college credits that's
basically like saying you're giving x
amount of money to them within an
educational delivery oh that's so it's
like
going to we need to we need some interns
cook for sure we got to do some some
some credit cooking you can hop on once
you get approved by like the little uc
system or whatever private college
you're going indeed and put the [ __ ] out
and then people just applaud you
indeed.com is a great sponsor of the
bootleg cab show by the way oh there it
is go to indeed.com
credit today and get your resume skills
test anyway go ahead there it is
but yeah i think that's the biggest one
like
being able to have extra hands [ __ ] the
[ __ ] dom candy talk about like most
people probably think opm is just a
label that's a real business term like i
learned that in like business one-on-one
like my freshman year at college like
opm other people's money yeah using
other people's money that's a literal
business term like through credit
through credit lines through loans and
just making sure like you're not using
your own physical cash yeah you're
leveraging someone else's money to you
know so
that's something that i think there's
like
depending on who you talk to there's
mixed
perceptions on that yeah because there's
some people who are like have zero debt
always yeah if you can't afford it
you know but then there's other there
but most
most people that i know like to leverage
debt in their favor facts because it's
like i mean credit is pretty much just
your history of borrowing money so at
the end of the day the bigger [ __ ] you
want to buy is the bigger record of [ __ ]
you have to have on your record of
actually borrowing and paying it back
even if you can even if you got the
money all right i'm still like i can go
buy a macbook right now i just bought a
brand new desktop computer but i just uh
financed it just because just so it
could just come out my account and just
add to my credit score to show like i'm
still paying or something in a positive
way so i mean it's just so many like
life hacks when they come to like
finances and financial literacy i think
it's out there just to research it
though yeah i watched so many youtube
videos because like you know uh
especially with the credit thing like i
always i started telling a lot of people
close to me like yo if you can afford
to just
use your credit card for everything but
you have to pay it off to zero every
month or you're gonna get you know
credit card
interest rates are interest rates
they're horrible so i'm gonna give you
another hack though
so if say if you got too much money on a
credit card let's you know they give you
like 12 to 16 months free
you can do a balance transfer to a brand
new credit card and transfer your whole
balance and get a whole another 16
months on a new credit card with that
same balance without the interest rate
without the interest rate wow
so that's what most people really be
doing like they'll open up a credit card
with union bank
run up like 10 15 000
until the year hit up and at the end of
the year if they're not ready to pay
that off all they're doing is just
switching that balance transfer over to
another bank yeah and they giving you
another 16 months to be like oh i just
use my credit card for everything and
then i just pay it down to like two
dollars every month no in fact that's
what i do as well because i don't even i
don't even want to go through because
then if you use your credit card and
some some some [ __ ] happens or
it's it's you're totally not liable for
it you know like it's
if you use your debit card all the time
let's say you swipe it at the gas
station and someone [ __ ] takes your
[ __ ]
that's your actual money that's missing
that's your money that's gone and then
now you gotta wait for the bank to get
their [ __ ] together that happens with
your credit card you're like oh well
[ __ ] it i'm cancelling my card you guys
will figure that [ __ ] out it's not
coming out of my house
yeah i'm gonna pay my money yeah but
that's a great way to like just build
your credit right it's just
yeah credit is uh
like not a lot of like like there's a
lot of misconceptions about how people
get credit
people like man i gotta have my phone
for
six years bro i'm like that [ __ ] don't
matter i said do not matter bro it only
matters if you don't pay it card notes
leases
house notes real [ __ ] you gotta finance
credit cards everyone should get a
credit card and then another thing you
can do is
you can add like if you have kids you
can add your children
as an authorized user on your credit
card right to start building their
clients so my mom got me right yeah my
mom taught me all this [ __ ] so i was
like definitely early on she was on my
ass about credit card utilization all
that type of stuff um
so
forgive me for not knowing this often i
know you guys just really there was a
press release that just came out
recently about what what you guys are
doing next year educators we did an
admin deal um
[ __ ] right yeah well we're in the chapel
and so we pretty we did that with ryan
press
press um
so but then we also did one for eagle as
well so we got a joint venture at red
bull
with with eagle so we just did the same
thing the co-publishing with
blast and with eagle as well because we
got art assigned to us as well so who's
artist jay million okay yeah yeah so i
mean he's been working with us for a
minute
um
but you know he falls under that whole
eagle bracket yeah producer
do a lot of stuff you you'll hear his
tag you did half the six tape too
the um pub thing is interesting too
because it's also another
avenue in which people have uh
traditionally gotten over on creatives
right you think about the uh mdrc [ __ ]
um which is i guess kind of out now i've
heard like it's very very frowned upon
if like a pub company offers you that
because it's very predatory yeah it's
super predatory i mean i'm sure they're
still in this day well i'm saying i'm
sure people are still signing those for
sure but like we think of like what
hitboy was talking about recently you
know and hip boy was in a really bad
situation um
so i mean obviously you guys took your
time with getting a pub situation
because yeah for sure i mean it just
like like i said like we did so much
with in the merchandising space early on
i know i've bought a bunch of [ __ ] so
bro
i think we probably made like a good
20 30 000 off just the first two three
week sales and no love lost merchandise
when you dropped our project so it was
like we were doing so much in the space
of merchandise and then these red bull
activations and then actually him
like walk through money was so crazy
this year just because it was like we
were on the left we was in a perfect
situation to where
he wasn't too big to do a small club and
do a walk through there but at the same
time like he wasn't too small to not do
some premier [ __ ] in there like too
though so
just from those two spectrums and we was
actually like managing the money
properly it was just like we could
really take our time
see what this [ __ ] actually mean
our lawyer he teaches music publishing
so that's like his class at drexel
university so that's like his specialty
with all of it so he was just taking his
time with actually getting relationships
with these right people and actually
building leverage at the same time hell
yeah see who can actually come through
though like seeing who can really
deliver on what they was talking about
so we've been going through this process
for like a year and some change
yeah
explain to me um
for i know why but people might not
understand when you guys announced the
initial tour run
blast probably could have done like the
hollywood bowl
yeah but you guys did the roxy
which
was dope because you guys did two nights
um but from the outside looking in
people might be like why the [ __ ] is
blast doing the roxy like he's the
biggest artist in in the city he's big
stars in the state you know what i mean
like yeah so kind of explain why artists
do that because that's it the same thing
happened
um
when roddy went on his first tour
um like his first big tour obviously but
like he was doing venues that like
most people be like yeah well the [ __ ]
sold out in 24 hours like he could have
did this or but there's a reason why
like yeah i mean
so everything matter like when it comes
down to ticket sales like ticket sales
is damn near like
your your good name in the streets you
know i'm saying when it comes to booking
festivals artists are getting the ticket
that they're getting on festivals
because what they doing today
independent show ticket sales so
we already understood what blaz going
into festival season um also with him
that's his first tour ever
so him having a gang stage presence
we actually let alice in and hired her
internally as a tour manager she's a
first-time tour manager so
we were thinking about scaling the
business before anything right like we
understand we got to scale the business
properly to what blast talent is right
even though he could have played bigger
shows right us as a company may not have
been suitable enough just to have the
right operations you know what i'm
saying to to maneuver throughout these
places on tour deal with that many
people fulfill that much merch and all
that type of stuff so we just wanted to
give ourselves a sample size one and
then two it was a part of tradition like
blast had never played the roxy before
so it's like he want to play the roxy
still like he's like on new year's you
still want to play the novo even even
though we can do bigger shows than
lenovo of course and so on and so forth
in different cities yeah that makes
sense it's like like uh
he's blown up so fast but he hasn't like
you said it's like
you don't want to skip the
like everyone has their hey yo i did the
roxy
i did the novo and it's like just
because he might be past that it's like
you still gotta kind of you gotta honor
some legacy [ __ ] yeah you gotta honor
that on some la [ __ ] like if you would
have skipped the roxy and said he never
did a roxy show like how would that be
in your biopic down
like that's something that you want to
highlight because that's really to have
that whole block line down the line
that's like something to talk about
rather it did sell out in two seconds or
not
yeah i know for sure we know we're not
going back to the roxy now though
it's a it's a sweat box
for sure everything ever i've been to
the roxy so much but every time i go
wait it's gonna be so hot in that [ __ ]
man it's gonna be so sweaty yeah you
know i'm with you i'm with you go to
that rainbow spot next door or whatever
isn't that what's called the raid the
restaurant next door that uh
yeah all the little kebabs and [ __ ] like
that yeah all the like motley that's
where one of the dudes from molly crew
overdosed next door at that really yeah
oh [ __ ] i didn't know that it's funny
yeah in that netflix movie that mgk's in
yeah yeah that's i didn't know that yeah
wow that's kind of nice yeah i went to i
saw the baby there and that i took my
wife to eat there and then
ron jeremy was in the booth next to us
and
i was like yo that's ron jeremy and i
told my wife who ron jeremy was yeah and
she she was like why do you know what
the dude's names are
what's wrong with you i'm like but you
don't understand he's like a legend like
yeah he's ron jeremy like i can see her
perspective he's also a [ __ ] a rapist
who's in prison right now
he is oh yeah they like hit him with
like a like i don't know a solid amount
of like when did this happen like in the
last 12 months i've been under a rock
for sure for sure i mean i mean i've
been moving around i also do radio so
like you know we look at all every day
we gotta do our [ __ ] show prep okay
okay every random story that pops up we
have to talk about it okay i got you i
got you wait hold on time to stop the
interview because we gotta talk about
our good folks at odd socks man listen
if you go to odd oddssocksofficial.com
that's oddsoxofficial.com
use the keyword keyword it's a [ __ ]
promo code use the [ __ ] promo code
bootleg kev all right at checkout you'll
save 20 off they got i mean look at
these spongebob joints
man the ninja turtle boys you know what
i'm saying how about the naruto guys
and then they got the new odd socks
basics that are just like
they're just so fly man the tie-dye
joints they just listen man whatever you
need they got it how about some
half-baked boys you know what i'm saying
listen
the most comfortable socks the most
affordable socks the best socks in the
world odd socks so go to
oddssocksofficial.com
use that keyword it's not a keyword it's
a [ __ ] promo code
[ __ ]
bootleg cab at checkout save twenty
percent off man shout out to our family
at odd socks if you support us go
support them has it been like um
you know for you on some executive [ __ ]
like like you said like you've you know
you you mentioned uh some of the other
la
imprints
whether it's uh nip or dom or tde
um it's it feels like you guys are are
really with eagle it just feels it just
feels fresh it feels like
you know
it feels different than anything we've
seen coming out of l.a yeah i mean so i
think one thing big thing to note is
like also blast is different than
anything we've seen yeah that's all i
was gonna say like blasters and gang
bang so it's like it really doesn't come
with any type of affiliation you know
what i mean it's really just kind of
like the organic team that we built
internally but at the same time it's
like blast may do your gutter for hitter
jay far as i hit the j5 right i think
the hitter j3 hit a j3 he made that and
like kendrick yg problem all that was on
that in like 2013 type [ __ ] you know but
so blast has worked with probably every
single artist from at least eight
artists from every single hood from
compton to la whether it be making them
graphic design
doing a mixing and doing an engineering
they beat so i think people just respect
like the organic build from blast and
understand like he always just played
his lane and never tried to jump in
nothing else
and yeah bro it's just like
we coming from a standpoint to where we
not going into it doing a deal with a
major right away like we took a
real left field approach but and left
field approach was a gamble but it
worked it worked you feel me
i mean i'd say i say this like this the
thing is like was dope about blast it's
like there's no
it's one of the few cases in music where
it's really all about how good the music
is because black is is a very mellow
dude
i would say he might be an introvert
like you know
he's very chill like there's no like
doesn't smoke weed there's no yeah he
doesn't smoke weed he doesn't like he's
not wrapped up in no [ __ ] there's no
instagram antics it's just like it's all
about the music and the branding and
like i feel like for you that i mean
especially coming out of la we see so
much
where the politics of la get involved in
yeah i mean it's politics everywhere you
feel me like you gotta deal with them
when you gotta deal with them but
for the most part i feel like everybody
on our team including myself and blast
and even [ __ ] to security even engineers
videographers everybody just
we have mutual respect from our peers
just because again none of us are even
involved in the streets like we ought to
grew up in south central l.a but again
we've always played our prospective
lanes whatever that was and then now we
in this position i think people just
respect how we move and how we get
around and how we really not in nobody
else's business but ours um
what what is is the long-term goal to
kind of ride out with red bull and just
you know i mean right now i mean like i
said we got the jv with them we just did
that so
of course building out through the red
bull seeing the other things i have to
offer because again mind you we've done
all this
not in the office for red bull during
the pandemic yeah all of this has
happened during the past yeah so we've
only had two meetings with red bull in
the red boat office the one was to
actually have the meeting about if we
wanted to do the deal right which was in
2019
and
the other one was just this past
month when we did a 2022 planning
meeting so that's the first time we met
all the new hires all the new people
that we've only been seeing it's only on
zoom yeah right so just like actually
being able to be in the physical or red
bull now i feel like that's going to
take it up either another notch right
are we going to miami in may to do the
f1 event like red bull team they pit
team and the actual racer just won both
events so they're building a whole track
around the miami dolphins no that f1
[ __ ] is serious it's ridiculous right
it's like it's almost like you know we
live here in the states and we don't
understand like i mean some some people
understand how big soccer and soccer's
like i guess a little bit different
because
you know if you grew up around latinos
you understand soccer is a [ __ ]
a thing but like f1 racing
no one i don't know what the like i
didn't realize how big of a deal it is
right netflix shows right yeah blew
everybody mind but i mean you know just
even [ __ ] like that we're gonna have so
many opportunities to to cross promote
where blast brand is and integrate that
into a whole different culture that has
nothing really to do with hip-hop at all
no it's amazing but i feel like f1 is
damn near like the race the race cars of
hip-hop though it's like the hip-hop
nascar
what's the name of the um the guy who uh
is like the guy or an episode
yeah i forget his name he just he just
lost to the red bull
but he's won like 10 years straight
though so he's like
he like he's the person in this world i
can't remember his name i just think of
uh
borat sasha bear cohen playing the f1
racer who
joined nascar and raced ricky bobby yeah
funny ricky booby
yeah nice i mean you know just kind of
die trying to dive in more to what red
bull has to offer just from a brand
standpoint um
being like in blast position and being
such a staple in la hip-hop for a long
time that maybe wasn't you know like i
said he was kind of
you know la's best kept secret for a
long time i can only imagine
um
have you guys ran into
old blastic people trying to put it out
like hey yo we did this in 2016.
yeah every week
so how do you deal with that
do you like let do you let let [ __ ] fly
or do you say hey look man times are
different now nah i mean me i think
the whole point of having a manager in
the first place is so as an artist you
don't have to have those awkward
conversations like sometimes if you got
a personal relationship with the person
then yeah you're gonna have to have that
conversation on your own sometimes
because they gonna come directly to you
because they probably got your number or
being right
but for the most part it's me having a
conversation it's like
hey my music and it's like it's not it's
not like it's disrespect it's just more
so like what we doing with the culture
that we build in the timeline that we
just doesn't line up yeah just don't
line up
i say all business has to be mutually
beneficial i've had uh
at least once or twice someone play me
last records in the studio here
that like are old yeah like yeah you
know we've just been holding this and
i'm like good luck yeah it's never
coming out because i mean you know as
all like super peculiar artists are they
like
i don't sound like that don't worry oh
100 every artist is like that right yeah
it's so crazy like but this [ __ ] is fire
and like
that [ __ ] happens with my artists all
the time
we'll have a song that we love and it's
like a year old and i mean that [ __ ] is
old and it's like
but it's fire like just like you held on
to it too long yeah
so yeah we get that every day i just i
had that conversation yesterday with
somebody no he's definitely um i feel
like shaping up to kind of being um
the like you know he was on ross's album
he's on nasa's album i mean he's been on
so many people's but it feels like
some real nate dog you know kind of
filling that gap of being like the the
the hook guy nah and by the way with
having a ma amazing solo records that
are number ones
simultaneously in two formats which i
don't think nate dog ever did with his
solo records god bless him but um but
yeah like like you guys feel that too
like you i mean i feel like everyone's
probably yeah that's a lot of lines you
saying that for sure for sure and then i
mean yeah the hooks all the time like i
think blast voice is just super unique
like in an r b space because it's not
like he likes singing his heart out like
a chaser it's just so so it was so easy
to he like yeah he's like rap singing
yeah you know so but i mean he could
take it there if he want to so i think
like the ross record like i don't think
nobody really
ever heard blast come off like that on
the hook like right out the gate right
right minute at least
compared to his oh [ __ ] but
even now it's like [ __ ] people want that
sauce and they want that organic west
coast feel without having to feel like
they're being super cliche and like okay
yeah let me tap in with blast see what
he got going just to make sure that we
not you know what i'm saying skipping
over something that could be a good
long-term relationship um what's
something you you talked about being
around dame earlier what was something
you learned about being around dame dash
because we spent one night with him and
i mean man the guy was just yeah
profusely just spewing jewels the whole
time yeah i mean at the time i was like
so i was like 20 i was fresh out of
college so that's 2015. it's like six
years oh yeah that's a while ago i was
23 years old
um
i mean it just learned like don't take
it personal
like you feel me like the first day i
walked in the office
about the internship you asked me like
who the [ __ ] are you like why are you in
here
and i'm just like well [ __ ] it's either
i'm gonna get upset or i'm about to
start talking and tell these [ __ ] what
i do
so i got to talking you feel me but i
think just
understanding like again personality
types understanding like how to work
with certain artists because by the time
i got to working with blasts
i was like i walk in the park dealing
with
dame or just sitting in meetings and
taking notes and being like a minute
taking on meetings with dame and [ __ ]
like that um being a fly on the wall
like all that type of stuff i think it
just helped me move into the space of
like i don't really get too imbalanced
if people be out of their mind or you
know what i'm saying or really feel like
they coming off disrespectful because
most of the time it just be people
delivery at the end of the day and if
you take this [ __ ] personal just like
i'm not taking the [ __ ] home with me
this is basically work for real for real
so yeah i think that's uh something that
people need to learn how to do better is
just like
a lot of people take a a broad stroke
approach to how they deal with people
like they just deal with people all the
same way but if you know certain people
are certain ways you gotta kind of
i think that's just a good a good um
yeah
attribute of a leader you you know not
everyone's gonna take the same approach
to the same person because everyone's
got different ways they react and for
sure you watch uh did you watch game of
thrones when i was on of course so like
i tell people like who people be asking
about that same type of question
i'm like you gotta just treat it like
arya and the mini face guy like every
room you walk in you just got to become
a different person sometimes you may be
in a student position yeah
yeah it's like you know i'm i am nobody
for real so it's like that's the
approach you got to take like
yeah i'm i am who i am but at the end of
the day if i walk in a room with benny
boom
i'm sitting on the couch in the corner
and just really soaking the soaking in
the game or taking whatever order it is
that they had to deliver to me but when
i'm walking in a room with the eagle
staff i'm the person delivering that
message you know what i'm saying but
it's taking out the ego to understand
the difference between those phases
though what is something um from your
experience so far
up and coming artists we talked earlier
about how sometimes uh
we talked about
that the video behind blast would cost
15 grand right that's which is a lot
right that's that's crazy but what are
some things that you
see artists wasting money on or maybe
getting taken advantage of that you know
whether it's
video production whether it's you know
i it annoys me when i have homies that
are up and coming artists and they're
like hey this guy hit me saying he could
get me on complex and all these blogs
you think i should do it and i'm like
[ __ ] no no
like but what are some of those things
that you know
you you kind of think artists could save
some money on or that you see them
getting
took on a little you know i see it
happening a lot so so i think
one music videos
all right like
some artists think that they gotta go
pay a bag to a director and that just
because they got a bunch of bread in the
video and like a bunch of females in the
video it's gonna go right when it's like
you can really do the opposite like i
said like touch down on these college
campuses and realize like there's a
whole film department of a bunch of kids
that need work and there's probably some
out there that's actually gonna be the
next
who's who to be able to tap in with them
and get on that type of level because
it's all about recruiting from the
ground source so i feel like
in the digital
digital media space photography and
videography like
a lot of videographers get over on
artists just because they don't
understand like
the one two step process what the
difference is and having a steadicam and
the difference between having a handheld
camera like the price difference between
all that type of stuff um i also think
pr damn they'll be jipping sometimes too
because it's like explain that because
you could have that that background and
like yeah like
public relations is pretty much like
one people need to understand in pr
they're pitching your story to people
they can't they can't guarantee anything
you can't guarantee in the same way no
label can guarantee you to be on rap
caviar right nobody can guarantee it all
they can do is put you in front of the
people and hopefully the the person
who is pitching you has a good enough
relationship to where they're gonna
accept so that's what that is like right
like it's not it don't matter
about if you pay 5 000 to the pr you may
get three [ __ ] pickups it's about the
product that's on there so i'll be
telling people all the time like you
don't need a pr if you do not have the
demand for pr right now like i
understand you want to service some
music out there but that's what you got
google adwords facebook marketing
spreads you got all that type of stuff
to be able to
do back-end marketing for people to
actually get to be able to see it
because most of the times [ __ ]
not reading articles know it yeah i
think that the most like overrated [ __ ]
is like
you know back in the day
[Music]
your life might get changed if you ended
up on uh
complex or two dope boys or whatever
blog right but like hip-hop yeah
whatever it is right but nowadays it's
like
we're not even consuming like
media that way anymore like
unfortunately you know obviously those
sites are still very you know they they
produce dope content they do dope things
but like
you know there used to be a time when if
you got one of those looks it would
matter
yeah but it would move the needle but it
doesn't move the needle anymore it
doesn't because streaming platforms took
they pretty much their essence away
because if you take if you take five
grand and give it to a pr person to get
on these websites it's like you might as
well you should have took in that five
grand shot five videos yeah for sure
me personally i look at
pr as like
just momentum pushes i don't even think
them articles really be that important
but what i think it is is
yeah it's for your consumer to see like
oh he looks like he's bubbling up right
now oh he got a double experience like
re-information yeah just a bomb to drop
just to be like keep your momentum going
in but to keep the the channel noisy as
they say in journalism like keep the
fans almost excited like oh yeah this
[ __ ] is going yeah it is kind of crazy
because if fans think or see certain
things it makes them want to [ __ ] with
you even more even though that
they're like i i've noticed that i was
like sigmund freud the power of the
subconscious like you're playing
somebody mental so much and you you
present something it's instagram at the
end of the day like you present one
thing to them so much they gonna start
to take that in and really like
associate that with you regardless of if
you telling them that or actually like
just giving them a visual
of that [ __ ] it's gonna go the way you
want it to go if you if you consistently
because nowadays right there's like uh
our generation now what's it called
there's like all these ig pages that
people pay to get on right yeah and like
you'll see the ones you know
that are like
like okay this guy's paid for that look
right and and now unfortunately with
some of these pages it's like almost
most of them you could tell are like the
label drop in the bag so would you say
worldstar started that though for sure
because worldstar pretty much started
that whole business model right yeah no
for sure to get your [ __ ] posted and
then
but see worldstar used to really like
damn near
i don't think people was understanding
like what like google owned youtube and
all that [ __ ] so i don't think they
understood like
world star was just taking it personally
or money you paid anyway and just
putting it behind the ads and [ __ ] like
that so that's why i was picking up so
many views but
again it's a difference between people
looking at the the system from
the broad perspective or looking at it
from like a functionality perspective
yeah now the world start thing was like
uh
i had some homies over there um so i
never really had to
you know we had a
music video we put up on on their
youtube page that they did they just
looked out for me on for free but
usually they were char i mean this is a
two years ago they were charging people
eight grand just to upload their video
on their channel i remember i had a
couple artists i worked with like in the
past and it's like yeah they got 12
million subscribers i get it but it's
like
the other thing people don't understand
is if a youtube video is uploaded on any
other page but your own
right or your labels it's not
uh you can't put it towards your album
sales right yeah you can't monetize that
charger just because it's like a well i
don't know if it's the same now but i
know before you didn't yeah like it
didn't count towards your total sales
right like so if you wanted to go number
one or you wanted to go gold or whatever
like it's not registered to you what's
actually called your upc code whatever
it is yeah and you think of like damn
look at all that like someone like you
know
young boy who had a lot of his
relationship on world star or just like
someone like damn like imagine some of
those i mean
by the way most of those songs are gold
or platinum anyway but yeah but so many
people probably could have gotten a
plaque if they would have just yeah it's
crazy but also they might not have had
the had the you know if it wasn't on the
world star page maybe not as many people
would have discovered it i'm pretty sure
like you had a hell of a conversation
with artists that really just don't give
a [ __ ] to learn about none of that [ __ ]
oh nah yeah most i mean i think now
people are starting to
get a little bit more
interested in that i feel like though
the last few years there was a lot of
artists that would just come in that
were just like
what is my kid doing in there jesus
um
but yeah no i feel like i feel like
recently it it seems as if most artists
are trying to be more self-aware of the
business um
you know i shout out to russ i think
russ has done a good job of like trying
to educate people i [ __ ] with rush heavy
no russ is dope um
and
he'd be he'd be really giving like
honestly people really should just
listen like russ is not lying to y'all
right like he he's not saying you might
not like the messenger and by the way
russia to me is fire as [ __ ] but you
might you know i understand
oh he was amazing that trump's amazing
but but he's telling everyone the truth
you know he's like what he's saying is
like yo if drake or kendrick or one of
these guys decided to go and if drake
went independent it break it break the
record game yeah for sure because it
would like fully pull the mask off
and so i think that's what's dope about
what you guys are doing because you guys
easily could have signed with anyone
like i know this you know so like
you know uh to to to do the red bull
approach is like
it's funny too because i don't think
everybody was like
like you know people are trying to feel
like a little jab
dude me and when me and head saw that
[ __ ] we were like
wow
and you know i just think it was a warm
brew that was on red bull yeah um and
they had another
i just was like i just never seen it
work because i'm not hip to i'm not hip
to the rock groups you're talking about
i just know that i've seen rappers sign
a red bull yeah like i've seen it like
you know i mean bro really to be a
thousand would you like shout out to
rebel for sure like also there's a
difference in the prod product no
disrespect to warren brew but you guys
are like generational talents like when
i i l you can
whoever you run across a red bull ever
you can ask them just to fact check it
like
the first meeting we ever had were red
bull we was like we want to own all the
ancillary income all the masters we're
not doing the publishing deal with you
and we're only doing a one-off for a
short license
and they was like what
and then we came back to the second
meeting with like a manila envelope with
all the numbers and [ __ ] from distrokid
and all the products and then we broke
down the whole staff for the flow chart
and it was like oh [ __ ] like y'all
really operate as a real company and i
think that's the biggest biggest
difference the fact that we were able to
show
and actually communicate what our
business vision was how we've seen the
whole year going and then have the music
attached to it on top of that and
nobody's going into those meetings that
way well not most people aren't no i
would say like 95 most of the time it's
like you know you go to a meeting they
get a little spill i do this i do this
and it's like so this song this song
yeah yeah so majority of the time it's
just me and blast going into these
meetings because our attorney in new
jersey so it's like me and him walking
in i'm damned wearing basketball shorts
to these meetings and blast in a damn
dicky suit or something like that and
they talking to us like we just the
natural rapper and then once we get to
actually have a conversation and tell
them like what we want and the
breakdowns all this type of [ __ ]
like everybody jaw just be dropped and
they'd be like ah
like at one of these labels
we went they literally stopped this mid
conversation was like bro this is above
my pay grade like we just in this
meeting i can't even have conversations
about this type of [ __ ] that's so crazy
you guys do you know would you say you
pretty much had beatings with most of
the majors
i don't know a major we haven't met with
yeah we met with every major every
single one
damn
i'm trying to think
yeah was there a situation that was a
close second as far as what you guys
were considering
um
i mean i think when we after we finished
that one-off portion we were just
considering everything you know like we
knew we were at a different place in
negotiations to go negotiate with a
major just because we knew they couldn't
give us anything less than rebel had
already given us on paper so we was like
all right that precedent is already said
so we know at the minimum if our mind i
made up we can go do another one off in
another place match that same deal and
see what comes from that but
um we got some great relationships with
some other people with different labels
but
it didn't ever go that far to where we
was like biting theirs like [ __ ] what do
we do
that's fair i didn't get that far what
is uh what obviously
big new year show so so that thing sold
out day of shout out in two and a half
minutes that shit's crazy
two and a half minutes um
obviously we're waiting for the official
last album yeah gonna get it next year
uh
i know blast is gonna drop
probably something in between his next
album so another another another
something yeah probably like another
small ep
definitely you know music is still just
ramping up um
i mean blaz got so much music bro i got
a note on my phone with like 75 songs in
it so it's like you make music every day
you record at home every day so it's
like it's never ending
um but any more collab projects
uh
i mean i don't i don't know well we
don't have that on the calendar for the
collab projects but i also think that
i don't really think s anybody else
would be able to capture like the
chemistry like him and beno got and
that's not even saying like it's not
much larger artists that you know i'm
saying that are in beano's category like
in different parts of the country and
stuff but
just the organic build that it was in a
time that we were both in like nib had
just passed away
blasts was just producing for fabinho
and me know didn't even know blast was
an artist right so it was like through
all of that that's how that [ __ ] just
built so naturally and the sound of it
built naturally but
i can't see that being replicated to be
honest with you
let me ask you this because there were
some records on six tape to
pop out being one of them like where i
was like yo
this song why is i i'll tell you how
what i heard from the def jam side
so essentially like yo why the [ __ ]
ain't y'all activating pop out at radio
or whatever and they'd be like we can't
because it's black side on their side
it's they're not clearing that side you
know like because i felt like that was
like loca just the whole entire project
of records that could have went i mean
they did go crazy but i mean in terms of
like
budgets radio pushes whatever like yeah
i think that uh
i mean i think uh on that side i don't
think that really was like low-hanging
fruit for like us like for eagle i think
that's more so having to do with like
probably radio politics because you know
they was doing work and chosen all at
the same time right so you can as you
know you got whole range and then warner
brothers was working shorty shorty the
uh right
with
when it come down to like these radio
teams what i'm and it's my first year
working with radio teams but
they get hella feisty and like
possessive over that [ __ ] too so it's
like a lot of that stuff don't even be
making it back to us of having
conversation about taking from [ __ ] to
radio or like just activating behind
certain stuff but
even on top of it i think that both of
them
just were um
you know was in his process with day
camp and then where blast was it like
coming to we were still trying to
renegotiate the red bull situation
it just wasn't on either side i don't
think it was like available for us to
just be like full blown out let's go
crazy because it was so much gray area
in between like both sides and an
individual business or whatever makes
sense make sense so from what i know
i just thought that i thought a week ago
yeah we got three videos it was a great
[ __ ] project yeah we should did the
premiere did you come to the movie [ __ ]
i did not know we did the documentary
premiere shot the documentary all that
type of stuff
but
definitely i feel like there's probably
some music on there that you know if
more of the world heard it probably
would have went crazier but well there
it is man uh anything like obviously you
guys have been dropping so much merch i
feel like you guys drop merch often yeah
yeah absolutely it feels like you know
yeah i mean everything's are you is it
is this something that blast has direct
his hands directly on the designs or so
blast does all the designs
for the merch yeah all of them yeah so
all the tour merch it's probably one
design on the tour merch you got like
this little bobble head i think he
didn't do um
but everything else as far as like
the the sheets button right
all the different logos and [ __ ] that's
all blast
so he's doing his design part and i do
the actual manufacturing getting it
distributed sourcing fabrics all that
type of stuff so
so that's uh where can people go what's
the website for the official um you can
go on blast.com okay yeah oneblast.com
find all the products there sheesh
buttons t-shirts hoodies all that
there's a lot and then the artist you
were telling us about who's on eagle
when are we gonna get some solo music
man well i mean he produced the uh
he produced go to war with blast and
snoke
and then he produced pop out one of them
was a bunch of stuff so right now he's
just really getting his production back
so heavy the damage seemed like he
taking that same type of path but he
only 20 years old though oh yeah it's
like you know he's still working through
growing pains and understanding like i
said music math like he making money
doing all these productions but i really
hold them accountable to understand like
how you need to distribute this how much
you about to have to pay through taxes
all the [ __ ] we talked about today is
like my constant conversations with him
the last thing um
i thought it was i mean obviously double
xl has habitually left west coast [ __ ]
off of their list
throughout the years you know they're
obviously i mean
as most media is east coast biased but
um it was great to see blasts on the
cover yeah um
was that like
was that something that you guys just
expected to happen or yeah i mean we
knew had a long even before the little
publicity stunt like oh go vote
we already knew blaster's on the cover
yeah so i mean even through all that
type of stuff
i think that uh
like what you said earlier like the
music just spoke for like when we did
those interviews it'd be ridiculous
music they were just like what the [ __ ]
like where does this keep coming from
you know for sure and i also feel like
you know
we live in l.a
so we're in a very like
biased consumer market for the [ __ ] that
we think should be on the freshman cover
absolutely but i also have lived i've
lived in florida when yg dropped my
crazy life and yg came to florida
and sold like 30 tickets like it was
crazy because in my head i'm from
phoenix
i'm a west coast dude and i'm thinking
it's the biggest [ __ ] ever and then i
see with my own eyes
oh yeah it's different so i do think
like as much as like yes double xl has
snubbed some west coast artists i also
feel like
nationwide
they're maybe like like if we think of
like roddy probably being the only other
la artist like i won't say the only
right i don't want to say that but
but but there's like crossing over but
that's just like undeniably
yeah a superstar
you know like there's artists that i've
i thought should have been
what are we doing over there cook
jesus [ __ ] christ
um
i thought there was like you know i mean
i would have loved to have seen mozzie
on the cover i would have loved to see
you by the way that's the other just i
wanted to see him do a [ __ ] project
with him and mozzie mozzie i mean him
and mazzy got so much music shout out to
mazzy shout out to davo like them is
like two of the
two of the early people i'm not just one
of my favorite rappers in the world so
oh my mozzie's a good person no he's the
best dave dave's the best
that would be to me
outside of the beano [ __ ]
there's so much music between blast and
mozzie i would agree with that though
that that would be the most natural
other thing if they did a little four or
five piece for the streets i think they
both bring something different they both
got like super significant voices and
the fact that mozzie can like really rap
rap and float like when they did timing
is perfect
i really went to sat in the corner for
like three minutes and wrote on a piece
of paper and was like [ __ ] this paper
let me go to the studio real quick and
lay it the whole [ __ ] and i was like
whoa cause i'm not used to people being
able to record as fast as blast so
seeing that them going you know mazzy's
crazy yeah yeah yeah so you're not shout
out to davo that i think that would be
the only i think to me when i think of
like like when i was talking earlier i
was like yo
mozzie to me would be the most natural
like if blast ever did another ep with
someone yeah uh might be one of my
favorite rappers so i can respect that
that'd be crazy and they got so there's
something about their chemistry they
never miss yeah hey i'm telling you uh
definitely probably gonna get some more
music out of them for sure for sure and
then just on the like d do-it-yourself
uh agenda him and russ doing something
would be crazy i mean i know they've
they've done they've done records
i know yeah and i'm just saying in terms
of like you know that'd be kind of crazy
for them to do something yeah i mean
[ __ ] bro
rest brought us to his house all type of
[ __ ] and showed us his whole process how
he really be creating all that type of
stuff and blaster is definitely very
intrigued so what mike does blast use
when he records himself at home i
definitely don't know that you know it's
crazy because i think when blast was i
was talking to blast and he was telling
me like the interface he uses like and
it's like the most like go to guitar
center yeah i'm actually about to go
guitars and spend like 600 or something
and like you you can have the setup
blast cuts his ideas at home on yeah i
got to enter he just texts me and the
interface was like he picked me up one
of them
that's crazy
there it is man i appreciate you pulling
up bro thank you there it is man go
follow him victor ruler
uh new [ __ ] coming in the new year from
from the eagle team yes sir boom